(hip hop music)
- Today is the day we
become Abbi and Ilana,
the boss bitches we
are in our minds.
Are you with me?
Chya!
- It's coming, it's
coming! (yelling)
(hands smacking)
(hip hop music)
- Yas, yas, yas.
This is Ilana.
- I recognize you
from Abbi's Instagram.
- That means so much to me.
(shoes tapping)
This lighting is incredible.
- Yas, yas, yas.
Like, my friend Abbi.
- You got a friend?
- Yeah, chocolate brown
eyes, ass of an angel.
- I am not a mom.
(thumping)
(shouting)
(thudding)
- I'm wild.
- Yeah.
- We could really
use some Abbi magic,
there's a pube situation.
Somebody barfed on
an exercise ball,
and then it bounced down
two flights of stairs.
- Oh Abbi, I love you.
- I love you, too.
- You do?
- Yeah.
- You're my little cupcake.
- You're wearing a dog hoodie.
- It's from the
dog owner section.
- It has ear holes for dog ears.
- Fixed it.
(electronic beeping) -
Day 274, five hours late,
(laughing)
wearing a napkin as a
shirt, violently high.
- You druggie lesbian Jews.
(electronic music)
- Weed queen.
- Is that your vaporizer?
- Vape life. (laughing)
- No pain when you're
gettin' your groove back.
(smoke detector beeping)
No, no, no. (yelling)
(grunting) What?
- (beeping) you both,
you yuppie trash.
- (beeping) my (beeping) dick.
- Hey listen, I
been there sweetie.
- To my dick?
- Where's the bathroom?
- Where isn't the bathroom?
- You're not a
baby, you're a man.
- No. (high-pitched laughter)
- Chill out.
- Miss hot lady, you
(lips smacking) got it.
- Thank you.
(hand smacking) - [Crowd] Hey.
- It's kinda spunky, right?
- That's what she
said. (laughter)
- Jaimé, you are
the best roommate.
When you're ready
to become a citizen,
my legs are wide open.
- Thank you.
- I'm the king of America.
- We are poly, we are bi.
- I'm not bi.
- You're right, how
do I know if I haven't
truly tested my boundaries?
- I (beeping) you in the
ass the first night that
we did anything, I think
that's pretty (beeping) mature.
- Trey.
- Wassup?
- Wassup, hey.
- You must be très horny.
- I'm not Trey
anything Ilana, what?
(laughing wildly) (kissing)
- Ooh.
- I am at the farmer's market,
'cause this is so juicy.
(moaning) Uh oh. (laughter)
- There's no trifecta,
it's more of like a duo.
- Smart and sexy, she
is unreal, this girl.
(lips smacking) Oh my God, I do.
You are sweeping me off my feet.
(dramatic opera music)
- You are two lucky Jews.
- We think so, too.
(dramatic opera music)